our favorite horror movies often have
more going on than just a bunch of
monsters preying on ill-fated teenagers
directors occasionally offer nods to
other entries in the genre
sometimes in the form of a 4-4 breaking
easter egg keep a silver bullet and some
holy water handy because these are some
of the best hidden details in horror
movies
shawn and george sean of the dead is
basically a 99 minute homage to the
horror genre
obviously the movie's title is a play on
george romero's second big zombie flick
dawn of the dead
speaking of which sean chastises ed for
referring to the shuffled undead as
the z word any zombies out there
don't say that what that
what that the dead word don't say it
why not because it's ridiculous which
calls back to the fact that the
characters in romero's movies don't call
their antagonist zombies and when shawn
tries to book a date for himself and liz
his phone book features an italian food
place called folchis a reference to
zombie film director
lucio folchi the name dropping continues
throughout the film
we see landis supermarket a nod to the
director of michael jackson's thriller
video and for re-electric which is named
after actor ken ferry who plays one of
the main characters in dawn of the dead
and we can't forget knight of the living
dead's most iconic line
they're coming to get you barbara which
was referenced by ed when sean was
talking to his mom barbara
we coming to get you barbara in return
romero casts simon pegg and director
edgar wright in land of the dead
king kong vs tumatran rat monkey peter
jackson will always be remembered for
his talking trilogies but the filmmaker
got his start making b-movie horror
flicks
he paid homage to his past in his 2005
king kong remake which slipped in an
awesome reference to his 1992 gore fest
brain dead
also known as dead alive the animal
storage hold on the ship
features a crate labelled sumatran rat
monkey beware the bites this is
supposedly the same strange creature
that starts a zombie outbreak in brain
dead
and in the movie it's said to come from
skull island the same island that gave
us king kong
teasing the dark tower david drayton the
main character in stephen king's the
mist is a commercial poster artist
in the opening scenes of the film
drayton works on a painting of roland
from stephen king's dark tower series
which was later adapted for a feature
film starring idris elba other horror
movie posters can be seen in the
background of drayton's office
including the thing and speaking of the
thing bad dog
the 1982 horror flick the thing focuses
on a group of americans working at an
antarctic research station where they
encounter a shape-shifting parasitic
organism that perfectly replicates any
life-form it absorbs but if you
understand norwegian the film's plot has
spoiled before it even begins as the
film
opens a couple of norwegians are trying
to kill a dog which is actually the
shape-shifting alien they shout warnings
about the alien in norwegian
they can be healed
which roughly translates to that's not a
dog it's some sort of thing
it's imitating a dog it isn't real get
away you idiots
but the message to kurt russell and his
cohorts is lost in translation
with great power years after hitchcock
set the standard for director cameos
san raimi put his own spin on the
tradition raymie zoltkar a 1973
oldsmobile delta 88
appears in the evil dead trilogy dragged
me to hell and
darkman among many others the car
remains ash williams's ride of choice in
the ash vs evil dead television series
and who could forget uncle ben riding
around in the iconic car in raimi's
spider-man with great power comes great
responsibility but with a 1973
oldsmobile comes great cameos and not so
great repair costs
reimy vs craven sam raimi loves dropping
references to other movies so the evil
dead features an interesting detail a
ripped poster for wes cravens the hills
have eyes can be seen in the basement of
the cabin right behind the table where
ash and scotty find the necronomicon
this refers back to a scene in the hills
have eyes depicting a torn poster of
jaws
and in response craven put the evil dead
on tv during a nightmare on elm street
lastly freddy krueger's bladed glove can
be seen in the tool shed in evil dead 2.
raymie may have gotten the last laugh
but we'll let you decide it was the
better
your damn one-liners bones out of my
mouth
talking heads in stuart gordon's
reanimator
dan kane's bedroom features a poster
promoting the talking heads film
stop making sense you know the guys who
did this
[Music]
the rock referencer lose the antagonist
of the film dr carl hill
who gets decapitated by herbert west
after which hill's decapitated head and
headless body are brought back to life
by west reanimation serum
somehow hill's severed head is still
able to control his body so that's right
we have a literal talking head in the
movie
thanks for watching subscribe to our
youtube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
which horror movie easter eggs are your
favorites